bu
Enes konuşmalarına hedefini Ben
katılımcıları bir şeyler sormak kişiler
anlatmak bir iz bırakmak olduğunu
düşünüyorum En azından kendi adıma böyle
değerlendiriyorum Şimdi ben kendimi
anlatmam Gerekirse bir televizyon
figürüm mesleğim televizyonda başladı
ile tıp fakültesinde okudum
TRT bu işe başladım Sonra özel
televizyonlar var Sonra müzik konusunda
Yetkin [ __ ] Team daha etkili bir hal
aldım sektörde prodüktörlük Yaptı
yapımcılık Yaptı müzikal olarak yani
yukarı olarak derken prodüktör olarak
albümler yaptım televizyonlarda müzik
programları yaptım yani işin yüzük alsın
da Dolayısıyla konuşurken müzikle ilgisi
çok şeyler anlatabilirim ama bugün daha
hayata dokunan bir Konuşma yapıldı
istedim Dolayısıyla şöyle başlık
belirledim hayatı kurma yaşı Evet şimdi
bir soru sorsam size hayatınızı hangi
yaşlı kurduğumuz diye ya da hayatınızı
hangi yaşlı kurmayı düşünüyorsunuz diye
Şimdi bu soruyu hafızamızın bir yerinde
şöyle bir not edin oraya kaydedin onun
Çünkü ben bu soruyu sorduğumda Sizler
eminim ki bir yaş Ailesi yaptınız
bırakamayız yaptınız orada net bir
şekilde kalsın Dursun
ve buradan hemen 2013 yılına gidelim
2012 yılında İstanbul'da Marmaray
Projesi ile ilgili olarak kazı çalışması
yapılırken
yenikapıda antik bir kent E rastlandığı
bu antik kentteki
bulgularda insan iskeletleri de vardı bu
iskeletleri incelendiğinde gördüler ki
bu iskeletler 37 35 yıl yaşamışlar hemen
hemen hepsi böyle ya Bu niye ortaya
koyuyor Milattan önce 5'inci ve 6'ncı
yüzyıla ait olanı bulgular bize şunu
söylüyor o yüzyılda insan hayatı Maximum
35 yıldır Şimdi size ilk Sorduğum soru
hayatı kurma yaşı nedir sorusunun
cevabını vermiştiniz yani o hafızanızı
bir yerde kilitlendi sonra açacağız onu
şimdi şu soruyu sorayım ben size insan
35 yıllık ömrüne ve sığdırabilir bir ve
bu sorunun yanıtında Lütfen siz kendi
akıl süzgecinden geçirin notlarınızı
kaydedin ve onu da biri kilitleyin
Evet şimdi milattan önce 5'inci 6'ncı
yüzyılda insan ömrü 30-35 yıl Cannes
1950'li yıllara geldiğimizde biraz
matematiksel bilgiler vermek istiyorum
belki bazen uzundur biliyor yine de
bilginizi tazeleyelim
beni Kuzeyli vardı insan ömrü yaklaşık
46 yıldızı ve o yıldan bu yana geçen
süreçte 20-25 yıl daha artı insanlar bu
da ne ilgisi var tabii ki teknolojinin
bilimin çok etkisi var Dolayısıyla
Bundan sonraki süreçte de bu sayı
artacaktır Geçenlerde yazı okudum en son
en yaşlı insan öldüğünde 122 yaşındaymış
bilim adamları o yaşa kadar yaşamanın
yolunu arıyorlar bu ise bu büyük bir
hedef İnsanlık adına ama
önemli olan Çok yaşamak dolu yaşamak
mesele bu
şimdi Dünya Sağlık Örgütü'nün
güncelliği bir yaş değil mi var ekranda
görüyorsunuz Bu Bu neden güncellendi
şundan dolayı Çünkü Dünya nüfusu daha
yaşlı bir hal aldı her geçen gün de bu
şekilde yol almaya devam ediyor
gördüğünüz gibi sıfır onyedi yaş arası
Ergen 18 65 yaş arası genç 66 79 yaş
arası orta yaş 80 99 yaş arası ise
yaşlı oraya yılı yazmışlar O yanlış
yaşlı olacak evet şimdi bu salona
baktığımda gençler var ve orta yaşlılar
var Öyle değil mi Ama orta yaşlardaki
sanıyorum yok hepimiz geleceğiz
hepimiz
hepimiz geleceğiz çok güzel
ama arkadaşlar
bu 80 90 9yaş ciddi bir yaş yaşamak
ister misiniz
istedim olmaz ama ayakta sağlam yani
öyle gitmek istedim ama ben 99 yaşına
kadar yaşamışım
bu içi boş bir hayat sürmüşüm neye yarar
Önemli olan bana göre size göre nedir
bilemem ama bana göre çok uzun ömürlü
olmak değil de çok dolu dolu yaşamak çok
sağlam yaşamak çok zengin Yaşamak bu
zenginlik maddiyattan söz edilen bir
zenginlik değil manevi tarafı güçlü olan
eser vermek yani insan hayatında gün
gelip veda ettiğinde bu yaşama bir eser
vermek Şimdi burada
ben tabii ki bu konuşma yaparken nereden
yola çıktım Hani işi müzik olan adam
veren buraya geliyor da hayatı kuru yaş
ile ilgili olarak size bir şeyler
anlatmaya çalışıyor İlber Ortaylı
hocanın kitabı var
hayatı iyi yaşamakla ilgili hayat nasıl
yaşanır ile ilgili çok güzel kitap
okuduğum zaman tam o sıralarda Sizden
bana davetiye vermişti yani
üniversiteden kitap beni etkilemişti de
ben o kitap okuduktan sonra hayatımı
tekrar Şöyle bir süzgeçten geçirdim Ya
sen nasıl hayat yaşadım dedim kendime şu
cevabı verdi Evet sen güzel bir hayat
Yaşadım ve yaşamaya devam ediyoruz çünkü
ben hayatımın
ama her an her gece zenginleştirmeye
yönelik olarak hedefler koyan mıyız biz
Dolayısıyla ve bu esinlenme den sonra
ortaya işte bugünkü konuşmamızın başlığı
çıktı Hayatı kurmayı şimdi oraya
geliyoruz hayatımızı kaç yaşında
kurmalıyız
bu şuna basmak istediler Evet geldi
Arkadaşlar hayatımız temel olarak dörde
ayrılıyor 12 25 yaş arası 25-40 yaş
arası 40 55 yaş arası 55 ve Sonrası
Şimdi bunlar ne ifade ediyor 12 25 yaş
arası temel atma önemli temiz için bu
yaşlarda temeli atıyoruz binanın
temeline kadar sağlamsa doğal
felaketlere karşı o kadar güçlü olur
ayakta doğru yıkılmaz insanda böyle bir
temel Ne kadar sağlam olursa hayatı o
kadar güçlü tutuyoruz ve o güçle beraber
çok güzel eserler veririz iş kimse bizi
yıkamaz kolay değildir Bu bu 25'lik yaş
arasında geldiğimizde hayata temellerini
60125 yaşına kadar Şimdi artık hayata
Akman zamanı hayatı tutulma zamanı
25-40 yaş arası ve o süreç içerisinde
hayata aklımıza söz söyleme zamanı da
yaşamıyor Yani artık söyleyebiliriz bu
yaş aralığında
40 50 55 arasına geldiğimizde durum Daha
bir farklı kızım var olduğum insanız
olgun ve otorite olmayı öğrenip bir
kimlik oluşturuyoruz kendimize bu Kişiye
göre değişir ama temel prensip budur
yani bu yaşadığında bu prensipleri
hayatımıza yerleştirmiş olmamız
gerekiyor 55 ve sonrasında geldiğimizde
artık 55 ve sonrası tam bir dinlenme ve
demlenme dönemi Yani bu süreçte artık
yapacağımız çok fazla bir şey yoktur
hepside hayatı tekrar etmeye başlarız
yani
47/5 yaş arasında yaptıklarımız
tekrarlanarak bir iyi olmaya çalışırız
Ama 55 ve sonrasında harika eserler
bırakan insanlar da yok mudur vardır 14
birazdan örnekleri anlatacağım özetle
şuraya gelmek istiyorum
Evet şimdi bu yaşadıklarını baktığımız
zaman Sizce hayatı kurma yaşı nedir
bu konuşmamın başında sormuş olduğum
sordum cevabını hafızamızdan o kilit
yerden çıkardı Evet
evet çok merak ediyorum nedir
bu Salonu dolduranların sanmıyorum ki
hayatı kurma yaşı ile ilgili olarak 12
25 yaş arasını not almış olsun onu
belirlemiş olsun var mı ikimiz de
mi
Evet arkadaşlar hayatı kurma yaşı
12 25 yaş arası
bu Evet
Evet şimdi bunu örneklerle aç olur
bu ne dedik
Bu temel atma dönemi dedik yaş
aralığında Yani 12 25 yaş arasındaki
öğrendiklerimiz aldıklarımız sosyal
çevremiz
yaşantımızın Bize sundukları bizim
çabalarımız ama her şey ama her şey işte
Bizi biz yapan unsurlar Eğer buraya eski
içtiyse konuk 25 yaş arasını sorun değil
25-40 yaş arasında bunu toparlama
şansımıza ama önemli olan 12 25 yaş
arası Gerçekten de çok donanımlı bir
şekilde yaşamak ve gerçekleştirmek
birazdan örneklerle ele yoğururken
kendimden dediğim vurarak bir yerlere
doğru Sizi götürmeye çalışacağım bakın
en yeni İslam medeniyeti gerek Klasik
Batı medeniyeti gerek Rönesans bir
şekilde olursa olsun Tüm bu süreçlerde
Bu dönemlerde damga vuran İnsanlar 12 25
yaş aralığında gerçekten ama gerçekten
hayatı dokunmuş izler bırakmış insanlar
Mozart
bu şube bozan en çok klasik eser veren
reste ci 35 yaşında öldü şube yaklaşık
aynı yaşlarda hayatını kaybetti Oh bu
işi bir düelloda öldürüldü henüz 40
yaşında bile değildi 38 yaşındaydı Rus
yazar peşinden söz ediyorum Çok güzel
gitmeyelim Fatih Sultan Mehmet
kimilerine göre İstanbul'u fethettiğinde
yirmi yaşındaydı Kimilerine Göre 19
yaşındaydı düşünebiliyor musunuz
kimilerine göre 22 kimleri 19 ne fark
eder ki
125/25 bile değil Peki biz Fatih Sultan
Mehmet ile ilgili ne geliyoruz ili bilim
ve sanatla ilgili inanılmaz bir donanıma
sahip tarih kitapları da yazıyor
tarihlerde anlatıyor net bir bilgidir
Böylesi bir liderdi Fatih Sultan Mehmet
İstanbul'u fethetmesi dolayısıyla bir
tesadüf değildir
ama ben size çok daha güzel bir örnek
vereyim Cumhuriyet tarihinden kim örnek
verebiliriz Mustafa Kemal Atatürk
Evet Mustafa Kemal Atatürk bir askerdi
var ama
bir asker olduğu için Kurtuluş Savaşı'nı
başlattı
ve o boğazda işgal devletlerinin Savaş
gemilerini gördüğünde Geldikleri gibi
giderler derken ve beraberinde 19 Mayıs
1919'da Samsun'a ayak bastığında henüz
38 yaşındaydı ve bir sözü var
o Cumhuriyeti kuracağız ve onun için
yola çıkmıştı
bu ne demiştik
bu
25140 yaş arası hayatı tutunma hayatı
akma ve söz söylemeye söylemiştik
Dolayısıyla
Bu size Vermiş olduğum örnekler Aslında
bilimsel olarak sözün etmiş olduğu
yaşadıkları içerisinde 12005 yaş
arasının ne denli hayat kurmaya şu
olduğunu ortaya koyuyor Bunu hedeflemeli
yiz Çünkü bu konuşmayı Ben ne yapıyorum
Burası bir üniversite genç arkadaşlarım
eğitim gördüğü bir yer ben bir
konuşmacıyım Ben size ne verebilirim O
benim buradan sizi bir nokta dokuna
bilmem lazım
ve dolayısıyla yazı çakraları açmak
lazım Hayat sadece üniversitede keyifli
zamanlar yaşamak bilgi almak değil
Kendimizi geliştirmek daha çok donanıma
sahip olmak üniversite tek başına bunun
için yeterli değildir Bunu da aktif hale
getirecek olan şey bizim bireysel
çabalarımız dır Biz şimdi buradan yola
çıkarak Biraz da ben kendimden de muyum
ben konuşması konuşmacı kendi hayatından
örnekler vererek ki
bu burada anlatmak istediği şeyleri daha
Player hale getiriyor şu Ben Kendi
hayatıma baktığımda da Arkadaşlar ben 26
yaşında geldiğimde
25-26 yaşına geldiğinde bu sağ biraz
büyük kurmuştum Ayaşta Alem fen ve genel
müdür sıfatıyla çalışıyordu Ve aynı
yaşta Radyo beraber haftalık bir müzik
dergisinin Genel Yayın yönetmenliğini
yapıyorum ben yine aynı yıl aynı dönem
içerisinde 25 26 yaşında da kahvaltı
televizyonda ulusal bir kanalda kendi
program olan çok da popüler olan çok
eğitim kalan bir programın sunucusu uydu
Peki ben nasıl başarmış bu bir tesadüf
değil Evet şunu söylemek istiyorum
sizlere hiçbir zaman keşfedilmeyi
beklemeyin Siz keşfedilmek adına çok ama
çok çalışın eğer çalışmazsanız kimse
sizi keşf etmez
keşfedilenler var Onlar istisnalar
vardır hiçbir şey yapmadı Hadi kişiler
vardır onlar istisnadır Ama hayatın
gerçeği içerisinde
keşfedilmek için çok ama çok çalışmamız
lazım Ben de kendi adıma hayatı kurmayı
yaşının benim yaşamında 12 25 yaş
arasına oturduğu dönemi veya hale
getirecek çok ama çok çalıştığım bir
süreç oldu
bu şeker olmak istiyordum sonucu olmak
istiyordum Onu çok ama çok istiyorum
televizyonda iyi örnekler vardı Cenk
Koray vardı ise söz vardı güneş tecelli
vardı TRT başka kaynak yoktu onu
izliyordu bir hayal ediyorum ve onlar
gibi olmak istiyorum Bunun için tek
kaynaklarda TRT televizyonunda
girebilmek tek kapı orası özel
Televizyon yoktu
Ama bir gün TRT sınavı açtığı sınava
katılmak istedim ama sınava katılmadan
önce de maalesef Türkiye gerçeği
birazcık içsel ilişkilerinizin olması
lazım ortak dostumuz vasıtasıyla
üniversite öğrencisiyim dönemin İstanbul
radyosu müdürünü makamında Onu ziyarete
gittik randevu bir şekilde
spiker olmak istiyorum ben dedi bana
Evet aynen sorun karşısında verdiği
cevap şuydu başka hiç konuşma yapmadı
Ben senden spiker spiker olmaz cümle bu
Ben de tabii ki aktif bir öğrenci olarak
bu hayatı sorgulayan birisi olarak Neden
sorusunu sordu çok da aldım sorarsanız
ya bir hayalin peşinde siniz dir gerçek
Yüzleşme miz gerekiyor bir uzmandan bunu
alacaksınız ya da
bu Eğer ki sizin hayali ile ilgili yol
haritasında onun söylemiyor boşsa
yolunuza devam edeceksiniz
neden sorma verdiği cevap arkadaşlar
Evet şimdi Kendimi şu pencere aşağıya
atacağım Sen hala bana bu soruyu
soruyorsun dedi
bu verseydi genç karşısında Türkiye'nin
Dönemin en ünlü spor spikerlerinden biri
bir yönetici bir üniversite gencin
hayalleri ile bakın nasıl oynuyor hiçbir
şey söylemedim gözlerimde olduğum Hala
hala Tüylerim diken diken olur
ve o radyonun kurucularından giderken
kendi kendime şunu söyledim Bir gün
sahne meslektaş olacağız çok geçmedi üç
yıl üç yıl sonra söz konusu kişi
pisam radyosunda yönetim görevinden
ayrıldığı bir spor gazetesinde oraya
sarı yaptı ben aynı dönem içerisinde sağ
bu Televizyonda program uyudum O iki bir
şey bu gerçekleşti ve o spor spikeri ile
oyunu kişiyle Ben aynı sor gazetesinde
müzik yazıları ve köşe yazarı ya köşe
yazıları yazan bir kalem yani sonra
destek taş olduk şunu anlatmak istiyorum
[Müzik]
karşınıza çıkan hayırlar bir engel
olmamalı yapılması gereken tek gerçek
şey var ki o da inandığımız yolda
yürümemiz ama
gerçeklikten uzak bir hayal peşinde
koşmak değil
bu bastığınız attığınız adımların
sağlam olması gerekiyor Yani
şunu söylemek istiyorum burada
bu boş hayaller peşinde koşmayı kendi
kapasitenizi bilim kendi kapasitenizi
bilerek hayatta kendinizi geliştirmeye
yönelik adımları ben kendi adıma şunu
keşfetmiştim kendi kendime keşfettim
bunun benim ilk ofisim var Ben bu
mesleği yapabilirim Evet ben spikerlik
ve sunuculuk yapabilirim ama ben şarkıcı
olamam sesine kadar mikrofonik olursa
olsun Şarkı söyleme yeteneğin yok ama
sunuculuk yapabilirim sikaret
yapabilirim Peki başarmak için ne
yaptığımı üç yılda ben ne yaptım üç
yılda Ben telefonis hikaye sınavını
kazanmış olan arkadaşlarımın nöbetlerine
gittim onlarla tanıştım onlarla
temrinleri çalıştım aldıkları eğitimleri
onlarla beraber onların nöbetlerini
sağolsuna bana destek oldular kendi
eğitimi onlarla istişare yaparak
arttırmaya çalıştım sonra bırakıldı Bir
hocam vardı o da TRT spikeri bir gün
bana dedi ki sokaktan mı çok istiyorsun
takmadı
ya bu kadar ve sticker olmasın
sunuculuğa doğru yürü derim Başka bir
açılım oldu benim için ve sunuculuk o
zamanlar Mehmet Ali Birand gerçeği vardı
Türkiye'de farklı bir sorun tekniği
getirmiştir klasik TRT mantığının
dışında Neyse Özletme kendini bu
kulvarda geliştirerek Çok Ama Çok
çalışarak ben bu mesleği yapmaya
başladım ama diğer taraftan
Hedef koyarken de vs döneminde radyo
televizyon eğitimi almaya başladığımda
zaten TRT spikeri ya da Sonuçta olmak
adına eğitimi almaya başlamıştım özetle
şuraya gelmek istiyorum ben kendimden
yola çıkarak
12.25 ya şurasında
hayatın temelini sağlamak adına çok
çalışmamız gerekiyor diyorum ya Evet
öyle çok ama çok çalışmamız gerekiyor
Burada sizin hayatınıza katkı sağlayacak
doğru insanları seçin abone olduğunuz
yerde beklemeyin bulunduğu insanları
benim yaptığım gibi onlarla kes
ilişkilerinizi geliştirildi onlardan bir
şeyler değil çok şeyler öğrenin Bazen
hayal kırıklığı yaşayabilirsiniz hiç
sorun değil bazen o ilişkiler bir şey
vermezsen başka bir ilişkiye atmayayım
ama size katkı sağlayacak size donanım
sağlayacak insanları seçin onları
tanıyım onlarla teşvik mesaimiz olsun
mutlaka ama mutlaka hayatınızı çok ama
çok katkısı olacak mıdır Bir Şimdi bir
de şu var
55 yaşlı sonrası demlenme dinlenme
dönemi dedim ya orada istisnalar var
onuda belirteyim yeniden kendimden örnek
vereceğim ama sonra iki tane örnek var
bir tanesi Mimar Sinan
bu seviye Cami yaptığında yanılıyorsa
Mimar Sinan 90 yaşındaydı ya da 90
yakında
O bir yanın var beni dik tresan en ünlü
eserini 90 yaşlarda yapmıştı Hani
dolayısıyla da üretmek hayatı tutunmak
sürekli bu yaşam skalasını içerisinde
eserler vermek bizim elimizde
bu Eğer istersek olur Yoksa Yaş 55 olmuş
artık dinlenelim demlenelim her şeyi
yaptık Hayır yine kendimden örnek
vereyim
benim ilgi alanlarından bir tanesi
mimari çok ama çok seviyorum mimari eski
yapıları taşlıklar ve ahşap yapılar
hayatına yeni bir alan soktum yeni alan
bir restorasyon bu yapıyorum şu ana
kadar iki Eser ortaya koymak üzereyim
Bir tanesi harika bir Taşımı bir tanesi
harika bir taş ve ahşap yapının vücuda
gelmesi nerede yapıyorum bunları burada
yapıyorum ben nereliyim Giresunluyum
tireb oldu yani işin özeti şu yaşınız ne
olursa olsun 12 25 yaş arasında
aldıklarımız hayatı kurma yaşı içerisine
gerçekten hayatı kurabilmemiz hayatımız
boyunca bisikletten kalacak Arkadaşlar
bunu asla unutmayın eğer o yaş o eski
içerseniz
Üzülmeyin biraz daha çok bas Afferin
25-40 yaş arası aynı pek de geç değilim
ama olmasa daha iyi canım 25-40 yaş
arası açık larımızı kapatabiliriz ama
temel unsur 12 25 yaş arası Ve unutmayın
yaptıklarımız hayatımız boyunca bizim
yüzümüze yaz
yüzümüz bizim aynamız Dolayısıyla
bu Eğer ki O Hayat boş geçerse ifade
yüzde bunun boş olur Dolayısıyla bomboş
yiyor ifade ile hayata veda etmek yerine
yapmamız gereken
hayatı dolu dolu yaşamak ve eserler
bırakmak için yaşamak teşekkür ediyorum